The thing about directing is,
time is ticking,
and you've gotta
wrangle the actors.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
-CHERYL DAVID: Well...
-LARRY DAVID: Hey.
-I am glad you're here.
-Are you?
Never thought I'd hear those
words come out of your mouth.
So, this season,
I'm directing episode three.
And it came to be
because Larry called me
and asked me if I was interested
in directing
one of the episodes this year.
I'm with a bunch of stiffs,
the food sucks,
the drinks aren't strong enough,
and your hand is up my ass.
CHERYL HINES:
It was really amazing
seeing the whole world of it.
Because I got to hang out
with the crew.
Some of the crew I--
I really didn't know very well.
And then by the end
of the shoot, it's like,
I'd rather be hanging out
with the camera truck
than act crafty with those
nutballs. (LAUGHS)
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪